[Music]
[Music]
Christian Hayden Hayden Christensen yeah
Christian hated well yeah she's a she's
a pilot and what she gets involved in
and she part of the Imperial stuff and
then kind of transfers over into the
good side you can compute some one else
can do that better job than me we
allowed to say ass like bad ass isoka
number seven on the list it's not the
lightsaber I would have chosen the plain
white blade but look to each their own
I'm not gonna judge you some people go
to Pinkberry and they just get vanilla
that's that's your call you live with it
it's a fine flavor who was an honorable
mention why you that if there were if
there weren't other okay if they're all
[ __ ] because she's working and she wants
to stay on jakku to find her family she
wants her family to come back the echoes
- Luke had the Bourbon know and as the
producer of Jedi Council makes me even
more excited talk about Alec Guinness
just exude this warmth when he played
obi-wan Kenobi
he was so nonsense nonsense no nonsense
that's the opposite of no nonsense that
can kick your ass get in the garbage
flute shy she will kick your ass get in
the garbage hooch flyboy saying that she
was the one shooting tell any people
judging you down the let's to sit down
the hatch pine ball into the chute
flyboy flyboy what's the what's the line
oh no it's right it don't I know I can't
do too
what fun is that better than I thought
oh no my tongue is not rolling today
it's just not gonna happen that's that's
the best time guy that's the best thing
no I cannot Felicity Jones is one of the
top actresses working today whether it's
the theory of everything or if it's the
most recent one of what the [ __ ] is the
movie called he helps out this new kid
Han that he meets and then Daenerys
because I don't remember her name in the
movie who was it again heroic but it's
really return to the Jedi that he does
the most and he helps he blows up the
third death start so our second Death
Star third Death Star whatever that
planet is in the last Jedi [ __ ]
forget
[Music]
you